[Music]
it's no secret that movie stars can make
millions upon millions of dollars to
play someone else on screen but for some
actors money isn't everything
particularly when it comes to sequels
find out why certain household names
decided not to follow up a successful
film despite being offered a truckload
of money
Vin Diesel Fast & Furious movies come
out at a rate that's well fast and
furious
Vin Diesel was in the first film and all
the most recent entries but he skipped
the 2003 sequel too fast too furious
despite being offered 25 million dollars
diesel told hashtag legend sequels have
gotten such a bad name and I had started
to think of that first Fast and Furious
as a classic like a rebel without a
cause if we sequel eyes dydt the way
studios were doing at the time just
slapping a story together I'd ruin the
chance of that first one becoming a
classic ironically diesel used that time
to film The Chronicles of Riddick a
sequel to the 2008
that franchise was much closer to
Diesel's hearts so much so that he took
home a relatively meager $50,000
Will Smith with the Fresh Prince of
bel-air
Will Smith transition from music into
television and with Independence Day the
top grossing movie of 1996 Smith
transitioned from TV star to
full-fledged movie star when producers
approached Smith to return for an
Independence Day sequel Smith countered
their initial offer with a request for
50 million dollars for two sequels
despite getting shot down Smith still
considered being in the movie in 2015
the sequels director roland emmerich
said he just was tired of sequels and he
did another science fiction film which
was his father-son story so he opted out
Michael Keaton primarily known as a
comedic actor Michael Keaton was a bit
of a left-field choice to star in Tim
Burton's Batman films but both Batman
and Batman Returns ended up doing
incredibly well that's why it was so
shocking when Keaton walked away from
the franchise before Batman Forever went
into production he also walked away from
a reported 15 million dollars but what
was it about 3 Jodie Foster movies that
win the Academy Award for Best Picture
don't often have sequels but the Silence
of the Lambs isn't like most movies most
serial killers keep some sort of
Profis from the victims I didn't know oh
you ate your after winning an Oscar for
her portrayal of FBI agent Clarice
Starling Jodie Foster was offered 20
million dollars to return for the sequel
one of the biggest actor paychecks up to
that time but Foster's said no deciding
instead to direct a film about a circus
sideshow performer called flora plum the
film died in production and Julianne
Moore stepped into the role of Clarice
for which she was paid a mere two
million dollars Keanu Reeves the
original speed was lightning in a bottle
a huge box-office success
it made veteran actor Keanu Reeves a
viable action star and thrust Sandra
Bullock onto the a-list
then there's speed to cruise control
which ranks among the most poorly
reviewed franchise killing sequels of
all time
Bullock returned but Reeves didn't
reportedly leaving 11 million dollars on
the table after filming the physically
taxing chain reaction
Reeves manager had a simple explanation
he didn't want to do two action movies
back-to-back Bruce Willis in the first
two films in the Expendables franchise
Bruce Willis appeared alongside an
ensemble of faded but beloved action
stars to return for the third film he
was offered three million dollars for
just four days of work when Willis asked
for a salary boost to four million
dollars it turns out he was well
expendable producers refused the pay
increase in Harrison Ford got the part
instead the Expendables three co-star
and co-writer Sylvester Stallone tweeted
out that Willis's behavior was greedy
and lazy a share formula for career
failure Katie Holmes Dawson's Creek
actress Katie Holmes start as Bruce
Wayne's girlfriend in Batman Begins but
she opted out of the next movie The Dark
Knight choosing instead to film the
forgettable heist comedy mad money
Holmes told Business Insider in 2016
that she doesn't regret her choice to
walk away from a critically acclaimed
blockbuster saying it was a decision
that I made at the time and it was right
for me at that moment according to The
Wall Street Journal Holmes would have
earned between 1 and 2 million dollars
for the Dark Knight much more than the
roughly 250,000 dollars she got for Mad
Money Jim Carrey 1994 was the year Jim
Carrey officially became a household
name when he starred in three hit movies
Ace Ventura pet detective the mask and
dumb and dumber Carrey starred in
sequels to Ace Ventura and Dumb and
Dumber but turned down the sequel to the
mask despite a 10 million dollar offer
turning down that much cash Kerry told
the Los Angeles Times I don't want
people to start thinking about me as
like a money person as I'm not to me
that's a little Monopoly game that's
being played in the other room Hilary
Duff if you weren't a tween or the
parent of a tween in the early 2000s and
the Lizzie McGuire television phenomenon
probably escaped you does the executive
dick Cook was so confident that a Lizzie
McGuire movie would be a hit that he
offered lead actress Hilary Duff a to
movie deal for 3.5 million dollars
Hilary's manager who happened to be your
mother asked for five million dollars
instead Cooke said four million dollars
was his final offer and gave the Duff's
a deadline when the offer would expire a
day after that deadline Duff's mom
agreed to the four million dollars but
it was too late and that's why there's
only one Lizzie McGuire Movie Will
Ferrell Alf is a modern-day Christmas
classic and the revisit buddy the elf
would be to ruin the spirit of the
original that's a big reason why Will
Ferrell refused to make elf 2 resisting
the lure of offers as high as 29 million
dollars regarding his decision he told
the Guardian I remember asking myself
could I would stand the criticism when
it's bad and they say he did the sequel
for the money I decided I wouldn't be
able to I didn't want to wander into an
area that could erase all the good work
I've done thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to